Russian opposition leader Alexi Navan is
appearing in a court in a prison in the
village of merkovo on extremism charges
these are live pictures from inside the
prison the 47 year olds facing up to 20
years behind bars is already serving an
11 and a half year sentence for fraud
and contempt offenses the supporters say
the charges are politically motivated to
silence them journalists Julia shop of
Oliver's lifeless now in Moscow just
talk us through first of all what's been
happening and what we can expect to see
over the coming hour or so
so basically we're waiting for Alexander
Valley verdicts any moment its
announcement is being delayed at the
moment but we're getting pictures as you
said from the courtroom we understand
that Alexei navalny enters the courtroom
not so long ago followed by his lawyers
and now the judge the announcement is
about to begin and the whole procedure
is taking place in the colony where
let's say navalny is serving his current
prison term it's in the Vladimir region
some three hours drive from Moscow to
the east so it's a closed door
announcement the journalists are not
allowed in the courtroom and his parents
are not allowed there either they're in
a separate room in the colonies colonies
premises watching the broadcast so
basically we're waiting for his verdict
and uh we're waiting for some for the
announcement to uh to to start any
moment now yeah and we know that you're
going to be giving across that for us
but is there any indication of how his
supporters are going to react because
he's already in jail facing a long jail
sentence this is to many ways just
extending his period in jail what are
people saying about that
foreign
yeah so first the state prosecution
asked the court to send navalny to serve
his sentence in a so-called special
regime Colony an institution with the
most severe conditions for prisoners
forgive me for interrupting you and I I
do apologize I'm going to come back to
you in a second there is a line that we
are seeing at the moment saying that
this is only quoting Russian news
agencies coming from Reuters saying the
judge in the navalny case saying he is
sentenced to an additional 19 years in
jail that's pretty much what his
supporters would have been expecting
indeed navalny himself had been saying
that he was he was going to get you were
talking to us about how his supporters
are likely to be responding to all of
this news
yeah absolutely so nine 19 years as we
understand thanks for that well Alexey
navalny has been in detention for two
and a half years now since January 2021
he was arrested at the Moscow airport
when he was returning from Germany while
in Germany he was treated for poisoning
following what German authorities say
was the poisoning with a novichok nerve
agent uh navalny believes Nevada himself
believes he was poisoned by Russian
special services so back in 2021 he was
arrested and accused of violating the
conditions of the probationary period in
his fraud case and in March last year he
received a total of nine years in prison
and in the summer of 2023 this summer
new court hearings on another case have
begun and this time around he's been
accused of creating an extremist
Community he's under extremism charges
now and two weeks ago on July the 20th
the prosecution demanded that's navalny
be sentenced to 20 years in a special
penal colony with very straight
conditions and during that court hearing
navalny delivered his last word in court
urging his supporters to fight with the
current political system in Russia so of
course uh huge demand and a very like
you know heightened attention to this
criminal case to this court case by
Alexander Barney by the way not just
navalny but also a former technical
director of navalny live YouTube channel
is being tried now the
prosecutors asked 10 years in jail for
him so of course we're following the
developments but at the moment we
understand that his verdict is 19 years
in jail yes as we were talking about
before they uh this his hearing or he
was listening to the outcome of of the
case of the sentencing whilst he's still
in prison it was being fed by video link
um to him but also to other parts as
well we cut a glimpse of it there
certainly what appeared to be a kind of
media scrum a group of people from the
media who were watching this as well
just briefly Yulia give us an indication
of what kind of influence what kind of
uh importance navalny holds within uh
Moscow because of course navani has been
on the political scene for years and he
has been as he puts it jailed and
persecuted and silenced by the Moscow
government for for much of that time
well you know um it's it's a very you
know of course it's an opposition
activist it's a political uh some people
consider him a political leader here in
Russia some people call him a political
activist but so many people here really
consider him a victim of the current
political system as well because
obviously a navalny has been in politics
for quite a while
um criticizing the authorities for
corruption and basically for their
politics and their policies rather so of
course this is a very controversial uh
figure and many people do not support
him of course but of course his
supporters
um they really feel for Alex say because
they they say that he is a victim of
this current political system Julia
thank you very much indeed for bringing
us up to date in that Julio chapovalova
talking to us from Moscow